US.
AND THEY JOIN ME NOW.
JASON, HARD FOUGHT VICTORY BUT
WE STILL HAVE TO KEEP OUR EYES
OPEN.
DON'T WE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> ARE YOU CELEBRATING TODAY?
>> THIS IS BATTLE --
>>
>> ARE YOU CELEBRATING TODAY?
>> THIS IS A BATTLE THAT
SHOULDN'T HAVE HAPPENED IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
WE ARE CELEBRATING.
EVERYONE IS VERY THANKFUL THAT
THE TREE IS GOING UP.
>> Jesse: MARIANNE, WHAT IS THE
TOWN FEELING RIGHT NOW?
>> OH, I HAVE NEVER A TOWN COME
TOGETHER MORE THAN THIS DEBACLE.
FOR THE LONGEST TIME THERE WAS A
GROUP OF PEOPLE IN DEDHAM SAYING
THAT WE WERE DIVIDED AND US VS.
THEM.
BUT I'M SORRY THIS CHRISTMAS
TREE HAS BROUGHT OUT JUST A
BEAUTIFUL UNITY OF DIFFERENT
VOICES, PEOPLE THAT I THINK COME
FROM DIFFERENT POLITICAL
IDEOLOGIES, DIFFER DIFFERENT
ETHNICITIES AND RELIGIONS.
THEY HAVE ALL GOTTEN BEHIND IT.
IT'S HAD NEGATIVES SHINING ON
THE TOWN IF YOU TURN IT GLASS
HALF FULL IT'S OVERWHELMINGLY
FULL.
>> Jesse: JASON, ARE YOU BUYING
THE EXCUSE THAT THEY WERE
UNDERGOING A HOLIDAY DECORATION
REVIEW PERIOD SINCE THE SPRING
AND THAT THEY HADN'T GOTTEN
AROUND TO ERECTING THE TREE YET
BEFORE THIS BIG KERFUFFLE
EXPLODED?
>> NOT EVEN A LITTLE.
I THINK THAT'S THE LEGAL
DEPARTMENT'S WORDING, MOST
LIKELY.
BASED ON WHAT I HAVE BEEN TOLD,
AND WHAT I HAVE HEARD FROM
MULTIPLE PEOPLE THAT IT WAS ONE
INDIVIDUAL, POTENTIALLY TWO
INDIVIDUALS THAT KIND OF PUT UP
A STINK ABOUT THE TREE.
AND THEN EVERYTHING BROKE LOOSE,
YOU KNOW, IN TERMS OF SOCIAL
MEDIA AND IT BEING ESCALATED.
THERE WAS REALLY NO LEADERSHIP
TO STEP IN PLACE AND SAY HEY, WE
ARE NOT GOING TO DO.
THIS RIGHT?
EVEN FROM THE TOP.
EVERYONE WAS JUST TOO AFRAID TO
TRY MAKE A DECISION AND,
UNFORTUNATELY, THIS IS WHERE WE
LANDED, RIGHT?
WE ARE IN NATIONAL NEWS,
INTERNATIONAL NEWS.
AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE BUT, YOU
KNOW, AGAIN, LIKE MARIANNE SAID,
I THINK IT'S GOING TO MOTIVATE
PEOPLE TO STAND UP FOR WHAT THEY
BELIEVE IN.
AND, I THINK IT IN THE LONG RUN
WILL MOST LIKELY BRING A LOT OF
FOLKS IN TOWN TOGETHER.
>> Jesse: MERRY CHRISTMAS, YOU
GUY, I'M GLAD HAD HAD SUCH A
UNIFYING MESSAGE AND EFFECT.
YOU ALSO GOT RID OF THE PSYCHO
AT YOUR HUMAN RIGHTS COMMISSION.
>> WE NEED TO GET RID OF THE
HUMAN RIGHTS COMMISSION.
I THINK THAT'S THE BIGGER
CHALLENGE.
>> Jesse: THE BATTLE HAS BEEN
WON BUT THE WAR IS NOT OVER.
THANK YOU TOO VERY MUCH.
HAPPY HOLIDAYS, HAPPY HANUKKAH,
HAPPY KWANZAA TO EVERYBODY